this is the streamer I show speed and
he's about to accidentally expose the
scam he's been paid to promote
especially For Speed just for you
Paradox crypto see the moon Paradox
crypto to the Moon not only that I
actually ended up confronting the people
behind all of this and it didn't exactly
go well advertising 10x to 100x is that
a get rich quick scheme yes or no no now
we're gonna get to all of this but first
let's start at the beginning in what
started as a live stream to meet
Cristiano Ronaldo and give away ps5s
quickly turn into a nightmare after fans
realized the Meetup was fake and was
being used to promote a scam literally
they used a fake Cristiano Ronaldo who
couldn't play soccer and was wearing a
buy Paradox crypto coin t-shirt and it
quickly got worse the live chat started
calling paradoxcoin a scam in the middle
of this sponsored stream and called I
show speed a sellout which caused him to
get very angry you sold out they're
using your speed this is just sad
that is crazy bro like them comments
like that bro this makes me like that's
crazy bro the fact I ever made like
I just think of me like that it's just
crazy I hate that bro y'all so weird bro
it's crazy bro it's crazy when people
think of me as a sellout as I literally
sell out now to be honest I don't watch
much of iso speeds content I know he's a
popular streamer and from what I
understand he's followed primarily by a
bunch of teenagers who think comedy is
now we know comedy is subjective but I
do think one thing is objectively
hilarious and that is the fact that all
these teenagers and kids called this guy
out I mean just think about it the
target of most crypto scams is gullible
people and who's more gullible than kids
and teenagers so when those people see
right through your scam that's pretty
embarrassing and it got so bad that
speed had to mute himself to try to
figure out how to salvage the situation
the only problem is he forgot to fully
mute the mic so what do I do now
[Music]
foreign
now before we get to the rest of this
audio of speed exposing the scam let's
talk about Paradox coin the thing he's
promoting how do we know this is a scam
anyways well I checked out their website
to learn more where they call themselves
the future of gaming but the one thing I
really took away from Paradox is that
they're not one thing the Paradox
metaverse is actually seven things each
one possibly dumber than the last and
I'm gonna explain them so first up is
the Paradox game which has Graphics out
of the PS2 era which made me wonder why
they'd be giving away ps5s I mean are
you trying to make your games look worse
by comparison but it gets even crazier
because I spoke to the founders and they
called their game Triple A quality and I
took issue with that we have worked day
and night for the last year to make this
as you probably know you've probably
done your research it takes two years on
average to make a triple A game right
yes yes or no on average anyone that
does a bit of research in Triple A game
you know it's roughly takes between two
and three years for a triple A game as
far as we are concerned and frankly I
have to take Serious
serious that this is a AAA game yeah
this looks like
designing Unreal Engine I'm sure you
have
defined it but you admit
wait a second can you describe yourself
as an indie game you describe
yourself
to you but just give it you are
interrupting me of course you are you
you call yourself an indie game on your
YouTube channel and then have the
audacity to come on my channel and call
yourself AAA yes we are a self-funded
Indie Studio a UK based Indie gaming
studio Indie studio so yeah I'm not
buying this AAA game story because not
even they believe it and even for an
indie game studio uh things seem
unfinished I mean in one of their
gameplay trailers I found like the
starter weapons HUD in Unreal Engine in
their game so how many day and nights
did this really take this isn't just any
regular game of course it's a blockchain
game so they sell nft avatars which you
can used to play in game and if you play
in game it earns you para coins now
follow me here uh to earn these pair
coins you complete missions which
apparently require up to eight hours of
gameplay to accomplish and once you do
that you have to wait 24 hours before
starting another mission uh I guess if
you do that full time they estimate you
make 500 a week based on four hours a
day of playing weight I thought these
missions took eight hours to play okay
I'm a bit confused but whatever let's
press on they even have an answer for
people who don't like grinding
themselves apparently if you want you
can rent out your avatar to someone else
for para coins and passive income uh
okay so now you have para coins right
what are you gonna do with them well you
can sell them but why sell them when you
can lock them up and stake them forget
this even more paracords if you do this
your paraccoins turn into P Save which
then you lock up for a period sorry
trying to maintain my a composure here
you lock up for a period of 28 to 288
days the longer you lock up your money
the more you earn in a process they call
delay and get paid sure I guess now if
you want to understand how this entire
staking process works
um their flowchart will leave you even
more confused here it is and instead of
explaining it I'm going to label all of
this Ponzi nonsense this is a pro tip
for you guys out there if you ever see a
flow chart that seems almost impossibly
complicated uh it's Ponzi nonsense
they're trying to confuse you because if
you actually understood how a Ponzi
scheme worked you'd never truly invest
so I know all of this at this point
seems stupid but hey that's only the
first exciting opportunity for you
there's seven more so if you're not a
gamer they also give you other schemes
you can get involved in for example
there's the Paradox Dao where you can
stake pedal coins to earn up to ten
percent a year in returns and if that's
not your thing you can try the Paradox
pad where they promise 10x to 100x
multiples if you invest okay now I asked
them if they thought this was marketing
a get rich quick scheme and here's what
they said it's hard for me to be quote
professional when y'all are dodging my
questions if you want to answer
questions
advertising 10x to 100x is that a get
rich quick scheme yes or no no why
because
every single day of the week in the
crypto space please get knowledgeable
about what happens in the crypto space
so much of the crypto spaces again him
oh God
we got you gotcha we got you buddy
you're a Bitcoin hater you hate crypto
that's why you don't like us that's why
you call us a Skype cause you hate us
crypto guys repeat what back what I said
repeat back what I said word for word I
said
that's right on Twitter
that's right on Twitter yo I don't know
what the gotcha was here but uh anyways
from here it derailed and so we're gonna
get back on topic uh they also have
Paris swap where the average user can
expect to earn up to 20 on staking
rewards all right now if all of that
sounds dumb you can even get your
friends to invest too with with Paradox
affiliate
oh my gosh it's so bad uh every person
you get gets five pounds okay
whoop-dee-doo now the last one we're
gonna cover is paradox events sorry I've
got to take this seriously Paradox is a
very serious company we have to all
remember that so Paradox events is not
really a direct scam per se it's an
event company put together by the
founders of paradox you guessed it they
claim they want to sell you YouTube
boxing pay-per-view which is only
available with their little para coins
right which seems very stupid and like
it never would work only they claim
their first fight is Andrew Tate vs Jake
Paul uh I found this out because their
founder told me about it in their
Discord at first he seemed to be upset
about this supposedly being leaked he
says guys can we refrain from sending
the screenshot that was leaked about the
Jake Paul vs Tate fight in February
however I couldn't find these leaked
posts and a few minutes later I realized
this guy might be spreading his own
rumor and this made a lot more sense
when the same day he said I don't care
spread the word of Jake and Andrew so
wait you leak this supposed fight
yourself and then say oops I guess it's
out there let's spread the word guys I
don't know it's it's so cringy man this
whole thing we cannot we've got a
screenshot it's not confirmed nor deny
whether or not we are in talks to make
it happen on our roster on our clock now
if we do get to make the happen we make
an amazing official announcement to come
with it
um if there is a screenshots
you're telling everyone just like say
it's true I don't know why you're saying
our community but within our community
share around within our community
without all the members
I don't know what spread the word word
of Jake and Andrew let's get Paradox
everywhere everywhere though now before
we go further let's meet the other
Founders too on their website they list
Amy italio and facial to reek who both
seem pretty obscure I think amio like
sells a goofy University or something
which just takes 10 seconds of research
to realize is a waste of money this is
the only way to get rich in 2022 without
sliding up a business from scratch for
every person that you refer to any
Italian University you get 15 pounds now
I confronted them about this claim and
here's what they said it is an affiliate
program
where a person has commissioned for
sales
no I think saying that this is the only
way you're going to get rich is wrong
people don't get rich on affiliate
programs people it's not the only you
say I found the only way to get rich no
knowledge the only way that works as
well
but that's the thing because you're
selling a crypto now so you're buying
your crypto isn't a way to get rich no
our affiliate marketing program is
designed it's a simple product Oh great
another affiliate scheme like Tate let
me guess it's not a get rich quick
scheme it's not a get rich quick scheme
all right so we have that in the
background now the last guy we need to
talk about is a YouTuber named money
kicks Who's involved he has three
million subscribers and it seems to me
like he's mostly famous for being a
billionaire son and doing billionaire
Sun things apparently he has allegedly
bought 50 of This Disaster for 11
million dollars now I couldn't confirm
this myself but he does seem very
affiliated with the project sitting next
to speed basically during the entire ad
and my favorite moment with money kicks
is just when he tries to relate to
somebody who's explaining how he grew up
poor and eventually became Rich we grew
up very humble in the sense where my dad
was a taxi driver worked all his life in
Honduras we started doing a bit of
businesses
life is step by step you know 100 100
wait how's money kicks talking about
life is step by step what was your step
one being the son of a billionaire what
what was your step two like at that
point are you is he just talking to
people like hey have you tried step one
yet now uh this is the whole crew
basically behind Paradox and and I hope
I've done a fair job of explaining it
obviously the project itself is a bit of
a paradox to me I mean it looks like
they are kind of putting real money
behind this they're investing in all
these high profile streamers but it's
just all done in such a scammy way why
would anyone want a part of this I mean
I know I wouldn't want seven ways to
join a Ponzi scheme so that's just what
it sounds like to me um and apparently
to a lot of children and teenagers so I
think it's probably gonna flop but now
that you understand what Paradox is it's
time to go back to I show speed trying
to keep his chat from figuring out
what's going on
all right so look it's cool now
relax roulette relax uh why wasn't the
chat
the microphone I know I don't know
you know what I'm doing bro
bro
yeah I think it's a little too late for
that the only way to make this more
obvious is if he changed his name to I
show scams now I do have an update here
because speed has responded saying he's
not a scammer and regrets his mistake
stop spinning I'm not a scammer bro why
did he say his I'm not a scammer dog I
made a little mistake you know
that I wish I never did but I'm not a
scammer bro now what exactly you make of
this is up to you I think he's pretty
young like 17 years old I think
hopefully he's going to learn from this
and is going to learn that you don't
have to sell out your audience for money
um as for the Paradox Founders I think
they're still baffled that anyone's mad
at them at all because they think
there's no reason to apologize at all
according to them the claims of L scam
in this chat were just Bots anyways
that's weekly that's what you mean
so y'all are saying humans can bot now
so yeah this whole thing went on for
hours and I'll link the full VOD below
confronting them if you're bored you can
give it a watch it's pretty funny
anyways that's basically it